[Music]
so let me tell you the story quickly
about apologies is that okay tim do you
want to hear that yes please
this is kind of a perfect example of
i think the leadership of uber and and
how they were open to science
so
i'm scheduled to give a keynote talk
at our big annual meetings
they're called the american economic
association meetings so
these are annual meetings that take
place every january
okay great so i'm on the schedule to
give a keynote talk
alongside a guy who ends up winning the
nobel prize in development economics
named angus deaton
he's there to criticize field
experiments and i'm there to be
the the supporter of field experiments
so
i get picked up
at my house here in hyde park chicago
because the meetings are downtown
chicago just happened to get lucky that
year the meetings rotate to a different
big city every year okay
so the uber car picks me up
and
as usual i'm still working on my slides
but but i i look at my watch and it's
noon roughly noon and i'm supposed to be
on stage at 12 30.
so
the driver starts taking me down there
and we get about three quarters of the
way down i look up
look at my watch
and i'm like this is perfect i i have to
just finish this last slide i'm going to
walk in these slides are going to be
great
next time i look up
i'm in the front of my house back in
high oh
no
oh no
and i'm like no
what the blank is going on here
and the driver said well the app blinked
and professor you were so busy working i
didn't want to disturb you
i thought that you changed the
destination because you forgot something
at home
i said no take me back
down to
to the conference so okay so i get there
i run in everything turns out fine
but
that evening
when i got home
i ended up walking out to our garage
that's uh separated from my home and my
wife always knows when i go out to the
garage it means somebody's gonna have
hell to be paid
i call tk
and
i say hey tk
let me tell you about what i think of
your blankety blank app
and guess what tk i will never take an
uber again
i am just going to simply take a lyft i
said tk you can call your chief
economist a lyft loyalist oh wow he must
love that
so
so i said you know what tk
the worst part
about the story is that i never received
an apology
and he says well john
we haven't gotten to that yet
and i said we have now
so what my team did is we explored
in
big big data sets
how much business does uber lose
from bad trips
now here you don't want to do an
experiment because i don't want to just
give people bad trips on purpose
what i have to do
is i need to find for example tim
and then i need to find
tim's statistical twin in the data
and i need to find when tim gets a bad
trip
but at the exact same time and over the
same route
when his statistical twin
gets a good trip
and then i can look at in the future
say for the next 90 days
does tim who got a bad trip
spend less money than tim's statistical
twin
what happens is you do
in fact millions and millions and
millions of lost revenue
happened because of bad trips
okay so now i showed that
bad trips cost uber
hundreds of millions of dollars now what
are you gonna do about it that's where
the science comes in
so we ended up
developing a scheme
where we
did various apologies
within an hour of when a person had a
bad trip it's like one apology could be
simply a basic apology and an email tim
we're sorry about your bad trip we know
we should be doing better
please accept our apology
that's one treatment but another
treatment is the exact same apology
with a five dollar coupon
that please take this five dollar coupon
for your next trip
what we find is we can undo a lot of the
bad stuff of the bad trips
but nearly every time you need that cash
coupon
words just don't matter but a little bit
of cash with the with the apology ends
up undoing about a third of the bad
stuff so now we're talking tens of
millions of dollars and true to his word
tk could have said look
that's a great trade secret we don't
want anyone else including lyft to know
about that but tk let us write that up
as a scientific paper
and now it's in an academic journal and
we can all learn from it about the
economics of apologies
you